sorry Avery embodies Kiwi ingenuity he's
a prolific scientist and inventor Ashley
Vance he made a fortune in the
pharmaceutical industry and then decided
to dedicate his life to helping the
world's poorest people
hence the sir alright so cool house
I followed sir Avery through a wardrobe
door into his garage slash lab where he
creates his objects
everything in the house is whiter you're
wearing white yeah yeah I mean I'm a bit
like Steve Jobs I have two dresses I
have black for winter and white for
summer but the thing is that I know that
I've got 4,795 days left to live how do
you know that well because I've done the
algorithm analysis of somebody my age
bought in my time how much Chardonnay I
drank all that sort of so I know what
I'm going to do with the next ten years
of my life failure is really just for
people are unprepared you don't waste
time on things that aren't gonna get you
to where you need to go in things like
clothes cerebri is well-known for taking
complicated medical devices and making
them simple cheap and durable did you
make this in here yeah yeah this is your
workshop currently he's working on this
incubator
it's really is a litel pot because it's
almost like you know something that
Superman would be happy to be in and the
shape of it is really much more about
getting even air distribution and trying
to make it look all the Life pod costs
two thousand dollars versus forty
thousand dollars for typical incubators
the hope is that it could save thousands
of lives each year I'll show you this is
really cold this is oh my god very ugly
he also has this giant block of frozen
chicken slurry as a way to amplify the
nutritional value of trash meat after
Kentucky Fried have taken all their bits
the legs and the chest mate I make it
into this stuff
chicken slurry have a spoonful of that
later Saraya mixes the trash meet with
of all things
Kiwi this breaks it down into the basic
amino acids so your body can absorb the
nutrients more easily it's aimed at
helping malnourished children if you
take that then you're gonna get instant
energy you don't need to digest it go
straight across you've got this will
save millions and millions of kids lives
you know Einstein said the most elegant
solution is always the most simplest and
Keeley's have that a very practical way
of doing things if you take away than
the Wiis that you have often with things
like still in the belly and just have a
bunch of guys in shapes with a lathe and
a few bits and pieces they come up with
stuff but nobody able to